pour connaître peut-être définitivement
la vérité sur les conditions de la mort
de madame marchal c'était en juin 91
dans sa villa de mougins dans les alpes
maritimes
une expertise scientifique avait été
ordonné cette expertise pourrait bien
confirmer la thèse de l'innocence d'omar
raddad du moins est-ce le pignon de son
défenseur qui a indiqué qu'omar raddad
acceptait évidemment un test adn
explications et commentaires et
dominique verdeilhan christian hottin
sylvain aubin installée en plein milieu
du prétoire à la fin du procès les deux
portent l'inscription en lettres de sang
en 94 elle avait condamné omar raddad
six ans plus tard elle pourrait
l'innocenter
c'est sur la face intérieure de la porte
de chaufferie où l'inscription est
incomplète que les traces de sang
appartenant à un hommes ont été relevées
c'est le laboratoire de police
scientifique qui aurait mis en lumière
ses traces l'adn ainsi prélevé sur la
porte sera prochainement comparer avec
celui d'omar raddad
mais pour maître vergès il ne fait aucun
doute que le résultat sera négatif
est ce que cet homme et omar et omar
raddad de toute évidence non omar haddad
d'abord ne peut pas écrire il est
illettré et deuxièmement il n'aurait pas
écrit une inscription qui qu'ils
dénonçaient pour omar raddad c'est le
second rebondissements en deux mois en
octobre des experts en graphologie avait
conclu qu'il était impossible de
connaître l'auteur des inscriptions pour
les magistrats de la commission de
révision l'instruction se poursuit ce il
ne devrait pas clore leurs travaux avant
le mois de mai